hey everyone welcome to the TV where you
can find weekly videos on minimalism and
healthy living to help you with a
simpler happier life and who's ready to
detox
okay maybe you're not as excited as I am
about detoxing your body from all sorts
of chemical products there are so many
products out there nowadays that you
would be surprised are harmful to your
body and can actually cause cancer they
don't not right tell you this today I'm
going to share with you some of the
items that I use in my non-toxic
personal care routine as well as hair
care you would be surprised how easy it
is how simple it is to make some of
these things and can actually save you a
lot of money so let's get started no
list of non toxic personal care items
would be complete if I don't mention
coconut oil I use it as a lotion after I
shower I use it for oil pulling which is
basically a fancy term for swishing it
in your mouth as a tooth whitening and I
use it to make my tooth fixed when my
hair gets dry I use it as a hair mask by
applying it directly to my hair about
half an hour before I shower and
covering I do have to rinse twice but it
leaves my hair feeling soft and shiny
there are probably a bajillion ways to
use coconut oil I keep it in a small jar
because I do buy it in bulk and this not
only looks more appealing but it keeps
my big tub sanitary
[Music]
so I mentioned that I use coconut oil to
make my own toothpaste the way that I do
this is I basically add coconut oil and
baking soda until I form a paste just
for flavoring I add peppermint essential
oil this is optional but it makes it
very inexpensive toothpaste that is
completely natural and non-toxic I've
mentioned in a previous video I do not
use perfume because they contain
endocrine disruptors which can cause
cancer so for me personally I've been
liking rose essential oil lately but do
make sure that if you use these kinds of
oils that they are safe for your skin
and that you do not have an allergic
reaction especially with kids this is
not sponsored but I do use Burt's Bees
beeswax balm for my hands and arms
because I do have eczema and when my
hands get very dry I need something
that's a bit thicker that stays on my
skin a lot longer there are other types
of trans but I do like beeswax as far as
a lotion it works wonders
[Music]
on to feminine hygiene again this is not
sponsored just a product that I've been
using lately and this is a menstrual cup
I personally have the lily Cup compact
and I love it because it fits in a
pocket purse wallet it's so discreet you
can reuse it wash it boil it it's so
soft and flexible I did not have any
pain or discomfort the first time I used
it a lot of people do have a learning
curve but I have had a child and
everybody's different this may not be
for you but it is non-toxic and better
for the environment menstrual cups can
be used at night but for some reason I
just prefer cloth pads I've had this set
for a while for some people it may be a
little scary for me I cloth diaper and
I'm a nurse so blood does not scare me
but I know that you can just throw them
in the washing machine on the warm or
hot cycle and I've not had any stains at
all ever
these have been used for about two years
now and still going strong so onto
haircare I do make my own shampoo
however I can't recommend my particular
recipe to you because everybody's hair
type is different so while it works for
me it may not work for you
so my recommendation would be research
recipes according to your hair type and
just try them out for me this is castile
soap honey
aloe vera and some essential oils and
water and that pretty much takes care of
that I'm not sure if this really
classifies under personal care but I
thought it was still important to show
you because a lot of hand soaps are
toxic as well so what I do is I use
castile soap and I use a
dispenser because it saves me so much
more money you basically pour about 1/4
or 1/5 into the container I think I
poured a little too much it should have
been about 1/5 fill it with water gently
invert it and you're done I like doing
this because it does last me several
months and it saves me so much more in
the long run because of it if you've
tried this out and you like it let me
know in the comments and as far as
making it goes I actually do not have
non-toxic makeup because I'm just using
what I already had if you guys have any
recommendations for natural and frugal
non-toxic makeup please let me know some
suggestions down the comments I would
greatly appreciate that thank you so
much for watching this video if you made
it till the end please don't forget to
Like and subscribe so that you won't
miss out on my weekly videos